hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 1971 candidates serious it's
thickened up at Rossum versus Bobby
Fischer its round four and well if
you've been with us so far you know that
game one went to Fisher Petros and got
into some serious time trouble after
having the better game for the entire
game but he couldn't reach time control
and he resigned the move he resigned the
game on move 40 then in game 2
Fisher tried to groom for defense
against Petros and Petrosyan achieved a
brilliant brilliant victory ending
Fischer's winning streak then game 3
again
Petrosian was much better in his in his
French defense and the Fisher tried
sacrificing a pawn but he didn't really
work out so later Fisher was the one who
had to fight for a draw but in the end
the game was drawn so although the
result at the moment is one and a half
each but it could have easily been three
2-0 40 grand petrosyan this is game four
and during well some some times before
game four or maybe even during Game
three Fisher caught a cold and he was
really cranky about everything he
refused to give interviews he refused to
have his photo taken as you can see
there's a quote above the board from the
hotel manager saying how Fisher was
constantly changing his hotel rooms that
he couldn't sleep due to traffic but
this is nothing out of the ordinary
Fisher often had many demands so that
being said let's focus on game four and
it's very interesting and Fisher really
shows us how to prepare for a game when
you're not really feeling all that well
perhaps even when you have a cold and
you of course you will not have enough
stamina to perhaps play the game for six
or seven hours so it's very interesting
how Fisher decided to handle this game
and how he deals with another game where
pitocin has the white pieces so as
you've seen in Game two
Fisher played the groom for defense here
Petrosyan opens with c4 we have c5 and
Knight to f3 so so far the English
opening g6 and now d4
seek after Sun d4 Knight captures
somebody 4/9 to c6 and here Fischer
allows for the game now transposes into
the accelerator dragon variation of the
Sicilian so
we will not see a repeating of the
growth of Defense and the Fisher will
not be showing us what he prepared as of
course he did prepare something but okay
nice to have 6/9 to c3 and the d6 now we
have f3 knife capture son before Queen
captures on d4 and Bishop to g7 Bishop
to e3
we have castles Queen back to d2 and now
comes Queen to a5 and here a very
interesting moment what a Fisher often
said that he doesn't enjoy playing the
dragon variation of the Sicilian because
the white can always go for the Yugoslav
attack simply push to g4 h4 and cross
black but here as petro son already has
c4 on the board as the game started off
as in English and then transposed into
the Sicilian there's already a c4 at the
board this Marazzi bind setup and it's
not all that impressive to play do
Kozlov attack while having c4 on the
board because it's not all that likely
we'll be able to Castle queenside for
example if you Castle queenside here
then I can simply continue developing
Bishop e6 king b1 and after let's say
rook F the c8 and now there's a double
attack against your c4 pawn and here you
would have to go something like 95 and
here the Queen's would simply get traded
off on the other hand if you try
something like b3 this isn't possible
due to this Knight to g4 move now
there's a double attack against your
knight on c3 here and here you would
have to move the knight and black would
once again be able to exchange here for
example Queen captures Knight captures
with check now this move is playable
because after King attacks that you can
simply capture Queen and after King
captures night now F captures on g4
brush-up captures attacking the rook
rook moves and here you have a position
where the material on the board is
completely equal to bishops each two
rooks each six pounds each and three
point islands each so a completely equal
equal position so not something you want
to do if you're hoping to create some
sort of a King side attack against the
black King so here instead petrosyan
goes rook to c1
and okay we have Bishop to e6 and now
comes b3 b3 is now playable because now
Knights the G
four is pretty much useless the rook is
also not protecting the night here okay
rook a to c8 by Fischer I will have
Bishop to e2 and now comes a six
we have denied the d5 now offering a
trade of Queens and okay queen capture
screen captures and now comes Knight
captures on d5 seek address on b5 Bishop
to d7 and now rook captures on c8 rook
captures on c8 and rope the c1 I hear I
can see that pretty much everything is
traded off rook captures King captures
and now King to f8 King the c2 was
played by Petrosyan and after play East
six it was in this position unmoved 20
that they agreed to a draw so a very
quick game for from the match for future
Petrosyan but the most interesting thing
about this whole game is that it was
already played it was played in 1969
between Spassky and Petrosyan during
their World Chess Championship match and
the game did continue here a4 was played
and the game continues for some 20 more
moves but Petrosyan doesn't wanna push
for more than he needs here against
Fischer as you know the match is
currently the matches equal 1 to 1 and
half each
well now it's two each but yeah this
exact same position was already on the
board I will put a link to that game in
the description below if you want to
check that out as well as like I said
this is more 20 in the spot the patrols
in Spassky game ended in like 43 moves
so like 23 more moves were played from
this position but yeah here Fischer
didn't really didn't really try all that
much like we said he did catch a cold
and perhaps he was not feeling all that
well and he simply repeated a game that
was already played for some reason I
don't really know why but Rosen allowed
this I'm sure
it's it's his own game of horse he knew
this game but why would he allow it like
to be played out in in its entirety so
this is a one very interesting thing if
anyone knows the answer to this question
feel free to you know increase our vast
knowledge in the description below if
not I will try to research it a bit more
and perhaps you know
inform all of you on and why would
Petros and allow such a thing especially
with the white pieces so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank rich poor Golan and Nick
crystal is danny mccullough michael
Alberico and hostess santos for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon perhaps would gain 500 no
matter or would some of your suggestions
I've seen Ali lecture zero played a very
nice game in the Evans gambit so perhaps
maybe show that and then continue the
series will see how it goes so thank you
all and I'll see you soon